il ya un moment on peut pas parce que
les jeunes on a besoin de les structurer
la police eh bien il faut le respecter
et quand on dit d'aller pisser sur la
tête de la police c'est pas sympa la
violence s'immiscer dans les villes de
la violence on ne dit rien dans les
films et c'est la violence mais en bois
et ça passe pourquoi c'est pas tout à
fait pareil maintenant des huit jours
mais ça oui en fait c'est pas je le
récuse la comparaison entre le les films
et la musique parce que les films
effectivement il ya des films très
violent mais c'est une violence
descriptive
c'est à dire que c'est un scénario
fictif dans lequel il ya de la violence
or il me semble que dans une partie du
rap et je rejoins ce que disait laurent
seigne à l'instant c'est pas tout le rap
mais dans une partie du rap il y à une
violence prescriptive c'est à dire que
toute une partie du rap est devenu une
sorte de cri de guerre pour une jeunesse
en rupture de banc pour une jeunesse
abreuvés à la haine de la france abreuvé
à la haine du flic abreuver alami à une
misogynie insupportable abreuvés à
l'homophobie
bien sûr il faut pas amalgamer il y ait
ou le rap on est bien comme ça mais on
peut pas s'aveugler sur le fait qu'une
partie du rap est devenu une sorte de
2,2 fécale orale à deux secondes fait
kahlo 1e s and m qu'est ce que ça veut
dire sfz déjà basinger six ans bout sur
le net et avant tout ce troll sexe
masculin niktamère personnes leur ticket
d'or est affiché à la commente l aréna
donc vous voulez appeler suspense book
pourquoi du coup moi je veux revenir sur
ça me parle d'europe mais je sais pas
qui vous parlez aussi tu t'appelles
hossam courte et raciste je pars à six
étapes et nous sommes je m'appelle jean
mais siens bah moi je t'appelle au
sommet
la plupart des américains d'autre alors
ok au sein gauche tu expliques tu es ce
que tu fais ce que tu connais du rap
c'est les clips l'éclipsé comme le ciné
coach va mater un film au ciné est ce
que tu peux et veux signer ce que vous
voyez déjà pas sérieux ça me laisse moi
pendant leur garde mais les cochons
ensemble et fade actuellement parler
n'est ce pas parler ou pas tu vas voir
olivier marchal regarde jouer son film
de gangsters tu dis pas qu'il est anti
flics ou quoi que ce soit c'est quoi le
problème c'est parce qu'il s'appelle
olivier ya pas trop loin pour toi vous
pouvez marcher pendant votre prénom ces
suspects six tout court adacore ses
dirigeants un rôle cd clim nana mais
justement alors je veux j'ai
heureusement je ne m'en fais la même
chose je veux réagir à cotiser moi je
veux réagir à ce que dit monsieur zboub
[Musique]
monsieur zboub effectivement il ya un
problème parce que quand vous les gens
comme vous chante des chansons de haine
des chansons misogyne descendent des
chansons homophobes tous les féministes
et les progressistes qui a ici le
trouveront un report de ce que tu
connais pas pourquoi parce que presque
parce que parce que vous êtes noir et
quand il ya un arabe qui chantent la
même chose c'est pareil ça passe comme
une lettre à la poste
quant au rappeur blanc ou une femme
encore pire une femme blanche qui
chanterait la même chose mais les filles
sont aussi alignés qui se répondent en
touraine le progressiste de chebbi s'il
vous plaît musique dessus sans du rap tu
connais pas moi je ne le connais pas je
connais pas ce monsieur même si me parle
avec beaucoup de brio de ceux de sept
parties anatomiques de son corps je ne
le connais pas les semaines à venir
alors il dit mais moi je m'en tiens donc
une des plus grandes cités d'europe
balle fouet donc tous les jours je
côtoie tu te 40-40 petit et on s'est
tous malheureusement quasiment tout
suspense boom
comment ils écoutent suce-moi se bat non
avec la promo que tu vas me faire tout
le monde veut m'écouter parle d'une midi
de musique on parle pas des bandits
mages côtoient des jeunes et je leur
parle justement de
chanson chose que tu connais pas mais
essayez au moins de porter votre nom
chasse aux racines essayer pourquoi ces
gens au sol messieurs c'est vrai mais
pas non plus en ferry oui moi je
m'appelle jean messien à ce genre alors
que nous on va désormais avec l'image en
somme on va découvrir
on va découvrir le clip le clip est et
je crois que nos cyclistes c'est quoi
ces gens bien je n'en mets sierra
d'accord mais après et attendait juste
là dessus ça me rappelle exactement
belle belattar ce sont des gens qui à
longueur de journée ce plein ne pas être
traités comme des français qu'on les
regarde pas comme d'ailleurs au titre
alors le moche alors qu'ils pensaient
alors quand on m'a alors dit maintenant
france alors ne dit pas mais c'est à la
salle est ridicule nous un meilleur
salaire grotesque une tenue tire-toi
lawson dalet a l'air grotesque colombie
on devait taper plus drôle d'être
étranger messieurs du coûteux juni
arnaque et contenant une arme à droite
et non parce que moi je vis en france
depuis moi j'assume mon premier 50 ans
moi j'avais 50 ans a fait 42 années que
je vis en france
j'ai eu des enfants franc j'ai fait mes
études on line en france il ya encore
des tarés comme toi pour me dire voter
un égyptien attention vous êtes de
chameaux dans votre clip
ouais vous traitez jours mais sa tête de
chat montrera que c'est raciste un peu
non séparation annoncée dans celui
d'origine africaine ils pourraient me
traiter de tous les noms ça passerait
comme une autre mais l'inter est
d'origine maghrébine il traite de tous
les noms
tu fais l'interrelation belattar soit là
mais s'adresse à vous poser son morceau
sans ça je t'appelle tu vous savez vous
représentez vous représentez tout ce que
la france des tests donc voilà il ya
deux cas pas touchant raquel moi je
voudrais pointé le fait que les
indignations à géométrie variable sont
plutôt du côté de l'extrême droite ou de
jean médias j'ai fait une brève
recherche de différents styles musicaux
où on peut avoir des propos extrêmement
violents vis-à-vis par exemple de la
police et sur lesquelles vous n'avez
strictement jeu
mais rien ne les connais pas d'éclipsé
pas de chef ne pas parler
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler de
cette chanson et alors et c'est ça ne
vous choque qui racontent même à tuer le
shérif mais c'est moi j'aurais agi à la
chanson d'amour n'a pas de chérif on
marche à brac utilise l année sur et
bodmer en français le coach me met pas
la même portée
corinne charby comme une boule de
flipper
on est étonné le renault safran c'est ça
je crois les marches militaires ça me
déglingué votre république moi je la
tringle de mais bordel où c'est que j'ai
mis mon flingue
d'abord j'ai jamais porté renault pour
c'est pas parce que parce que jamais
m'anime étonné c'est pas moi qu'il faut
dire ça c'est à cyril hanouna moi je
sais moi non je suis je suis pas
animateur de sol je trouve ça attendez
vous des masques et à quentin quant à
elle me traitaient d'extrême droite
quand votre patron jean luc mélenchon
sous la lune vous les abonnés attention
et vous verrez qu'on a touché le fond
j'en ai un peu importe qui dit quoi elle
en a rien à [ __ ] puisqu'il intéresser
les sites et les focus et pas des cités
connaît pas les citer moi je parle de
niche bien sûr ça va pas plus loin que
ça fait donc là à mettre le contre c'est
parce qu'il écoute et 6 rue blanche a
beaucoup de talent mais bon le vent son
est bon après je vous dise rien dit
donc je vous laisse couler est exclu ça
sort à minuit vous avez été donc un
petit sur gens mais c'est pourquoi on
choisit long mais c'est ça une bombe
maintenant parce que c'est un bug que
c'est que ces histoires c'est que je
suis un bug dans le rang c'est à dire
que normalement à l'immigré est
programmé pour haïr la france et pour
rester immigrés toute sa vie dîner
credoc et donc l'assimilation c'est le
pire des lotois démété immigrés bon
arrête de raconter l'histoire
je suis français
vous attendez si tu veux rester immigrés
barrès finances et exige la pelouse
située fait gonfler soit français je
suis où je suis et que tu détestes la
france était un traître ou quoi
choisissons média qu'est ce que je
réussis par le d cit et sans connaître
les cités du coup moi je parle bien même
ils ont écouté le chinois sun zi ça
s'appelle donc j'en mets ici et j'en
mets sur des murs ou vous en pensez vous
aussi dit la vérité
voilà comme d'habitude si vous trouvez
que c'est abusé moi je trouve que je
vois déjà les confitures des petits
côtés voilà j'ai kiffé le songe et
kirill qui contient d'autres trucs qui
m'ont un peu dérangée trois clips qu'ils
viennent ces clubs de partout sur le
corps nous les romans et les robots
on va leur [ __ ] leur mère à ses fils
de
[Musique]
tous
dans mes triage en médiatisant mais
c'est pourquoi depuis n'étant des
revenus et les renards avec ta tête
jamais on ne sait pas d'où tu viens
la loupe jamais ça jamais dire mais
pourquoi tout est tombé je peux et les
rona
tâche amour toi aussi tu es un homme
seul
plus pop costume tient jamais fait pire
pourquoi qui fait le mytho son vrai nom
c'est au sol tabou sans le cas
qui parle c'est une tarte à tabou sur le
cac
tu parles c'est une tare
[Musique]
m
on s'en fout
[Musique]
là qu'ils viennent ces clubs doivent
tous sur le camp des troupes en place
sur les plages au j'aimerais bien toi
dans le ghetto raconter des histoires de
femmes jours à la tête de chameau
jean médecine ou si la vraie vie pas les
médias ont décidé d'éliminer racj a
déclaré
gens d'ici jean médecin pourquoi est-on
du rock indé
non avec tata motors ont fait pas tout
et bien que la loupe jamais jamais dit
affirmé c'est pourquoi tout est tombé je
peux aider les autres
elle s'est prêtée à ted touche amour toi
aussi tu es un obstacle
crois tu que tu fais tu as loupé le rap
était est un champ de haine alors voilà
donc ça sort ce soir à minuit ce
champion score non mais non ma leçon
j'aime bien le son après il ya
deux-trois pas la parole qui me dérange
c'est vrai mais nous en perdition
principal intérêt en fait c'est ce que
c'est une illustration de ce que je
disais à l'instant c'est à dire qu'une
partie du rap c'est un fait call home
haineux dont les saint-georges jeunes
vers les étoiles et dont les cibles
nouveau chanter ton prénom je peux je
peux venir qu'ils fassent la vérité tu
atteins pas le son j'ai kiffé soumettant
le merdy mais tous les jeunes gens mais
je sais que pouvoir mais parce que sinon
on s'expose irlandais cian je dis juste
que le rap et se fait qu'à lomé ne vous
allez vous que vous venez de voir dont
les six balles moins heureuses en
boucane l'environnement voilà alors je
te laisse chercher en mx2 de mon étoile
jean ferrat stade que tous jeunes ou
chanter au sam
c'est toi qui fais mais j'ai eu droit
quand j'étais jeune j'ai eu droit à du
racisme non sans toile j'ai eu droit à
tous les jeux de mots que tu vas y ma
vie